palun enfin pour refermer cette édition
les victoires de la musique ce soir à
l'olympia qui viennent comme chaque
année couronnée d artistes ou les
créations qui ont marqué l'année
musicale
michel viennent
un triplé pour alain bashung
à la fois artiste album et vidéoclip de
l'année grâce un disque fantaisie
militaire qui illustre l'univers
attachant ce cet écorché vif
subissant
la consécration attendue ensuite pour
faudel révélation masculine de l'année
le petit prince du raï dont la musique
chaude représente déjà avec succès la
france loin de ses frontières
un triomphe attendu celui là pour notre
dame de paris
spectacle de l'année un spectacle qui
pas déjà depuis un an tous les records
de ventes de disques
oh
des victoires de la musique qui ont
également récompensé axelle red le
groupe louise attaque
michel sardou et d'une manière générale
les musiques métisses et les musiques
qui ont donné les meilleurs moments
d'une cérémonie par ailleurs un peu
terne
on